uh Facebook's parent company meta uh  just announcing 11  000 job losses uh in the last few  moments its owner Mark Zuckerberg has  just shared the following a statement  with meta employees today I'm sharing  some of the most difficult changes we've  made in meta's history I've decided to  reduce the size of our team by about 13  and let more than 11  000 of our talented employees go he goes  on to say I want to take accountability  for these decisions and for how we got  here I know this is tough for everyone  and I'm especially sorry to see those  impacted so that's 11 000 job losses at  Facebook's parent company meta and of  course that comes after those job losses  at Twitter in the last few days as well  we'll bring you more on that as we get  it